Antes de empezar, vamos a ver un extracto
de uno de los discursos más recientes de
Putin.
Lo vamos a poner con subtítulos para que
podáis notar la entonación.
“Toda nación, y mucho más los rusos, saben
distinguir entre los auténticos patriotas
y la escoria traidora y, simplemente, los
escupirán como un insecto que se mete en
la boca.
Estoy convencido de que una necesaria y natural
desintoxicación de la sociedad como esta
reforzará nuestra sociedad y nos hará más
solidarios y cohesionados para responder a
cualquier desafío”.
Y la pregunta que os estaréis haciendo muchos
en este momento es ¿De qué traidores habla
Putin?
En este vídeo os lo vamos a contar.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
casi 4 millones de refugiados ucranianos han
abandonado el país.
Pero todo eso ya lo sabéis.
Sobre todo si vivís en Europa.
Probablemente alguno de vosotros está acogiendo
a refugiados en su casa.
Sin embargo, en el vídeo de hoy vamos a hablar
del otro éxodo.
Sí, hablamos del éxodo de los rusos.
Miles de rusos se han marchado, temerosos
de que vuelva a caer un telón de acero
¡Habéis oído bien!
En realidad, los que estáis suscritos a nuestro
Patreon ya lo sabéis muy bien porque lo hemos
contado en uno de nuestros últimos boletines.
Por cierto, que si queréis suscribíos a
nuestro Patreon, tenéis todos los links en
la descripción.
No sólo podréis recibir nuestro boletín
de análisis político semanal sino que también
podréis conseguir nuestro merchandising exclusivo,
que no está a la venta en ningún otro sitio.
Pero volvamos a nuestra historia de hoy.
Los refugiados ucranianos han recibido una
cálida bienvenida en Europa.
Y esto no es sólo por solidaridad con Ucrania.
También es por interés económico ¡Sí!
¡No nos hemos vuelto locos!
Los refugiados ucranianos son casi un milagro
para muchos países.
Por ejemplo, Polonia está acogiendo a más
de un millón de Ucranianos.
Una ciudad como Varsovia ha visto como su
población se ha incrementado en un 17% en
sólo unas semanas.
Y eso…
¡Son buenas noticias!
Casi todos esos refugiados son gente joven
que tarde o temprano encontrará un trabajo,
pagará impuestos y…
¡Pagará pensiones!
¡Habéis oído bien!
Con la calculadora en la mano, el problema
de los refugiados no está en el país de
destino…
¡Sino en el de origen!
Sin embargo, si la guerra termina con unas
condiciones favorables para Ucrania, es lógico
pensar que muchos de esos ucranianos volverán
a reconstruir el país.
Sin embargo…
¿Qué pasa con los rusos?
Pues seamos honestos: no.
No van a volver.
La diferencia entre los refugiados ucranianos
y los emigrantes rusos es que estos segundos
están huyendo de un sistema político cada
vez más autoritario.
Y esto es un problema para Rusia casi tan
grande como las sanciones.
En otras palabras: Rusia está perdiendo a
sus mejores trabajadores.
Informáticos, abogados, consultores…
casi toda la masa gris de este país se está
marchando a toda velocidad.
En jerga económica, esto tiene un nombre:
descapitalización.
Y donde hay un problema para Rusia hay una
oportunidad para el resto del mundo.
Porque todo ese talento tiene que llegar a
alguna parte.
Y, creedme, si hay algo que nunca sobra en
un país es talento.
Y aquí es donde viene el auténtico problema
que vamos a denunciar en el vídeo de hoy:
Europa no los está aceptando ¡Habéis oído
bien!
Y diréis ¡Normal!
¡Esto será parte de las sanciones económicas
contra Rusia!
¿Verdad?
Pues nada de eso.
En realidad, aceptar emigrantes rusos ahora
mismo sería un castigo añadido hacia rusa
¿Cómo van a poder hacer un ciberataque si
ya no tienen hackers?
¿Cómo van a poder recuperar su economía
si sus mejores talentos se han marchado?
¿Entendéis lo que quiero decir?
Así que la pregunta del vídeo de hoy es
¿Por qué Europa no está aceptando inmigrantes
rusos?
¿Por qué debe hacerlo lo antes posible?
¿Y cómo debe hacerlo?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes…
muchos nos habéis preguntado que cómo se
puede colaborar con el ejército de Ucrania
y la resistencia.
Pues bien, el Banco Nacional de Ucrania ha
abierto una cuenta para aceptar donaciones
de todo el mundo.
Ese dinero irá a financiar la resistencia
contra la invasión rusa.
Si consideréis que esto es una causa justa
y queréis ayudar, tenéis los enlaces en
la descripción.
Vaya por delante que esto no es un anuncio:
nadie nos paga por decir esto y lo hacemos
porque creemos que es nuestra responsabilidad.
Y si alguno se lo está preguntando: yo sí
he hecho mi donación porque creo que es importante,
pero es algo muy personal y no voy a intentar
convencer a nadie.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA NUEVA (VIEJA) RUSIA
El 31 de enero de 1990, McDonald’s abrió
su primer restaurante en la plaza PUNSHKINSKAYA
de Moscú.
Más de 5000 personas hicieron cola ese día
para probar el Big Mac.
Lo sé: muchos no os lo podéis creer.
Pero durante muchos años, McDonald´s en
Rusia era algo así como el sitio cool donde
te llevarías a una primera cita.
Un símbolo de la nueva Rusia que se abría
a occidente.
Pues bien, desde hace dos semanas, McDonald’s
se ha marchado de Rusia.
Así que, todos esos restaurantes que tenían
la gran M de McDonalds han cambiado el nombre.
A partir de ahora, los rusos que quieran un
happy meal tendrán que irse a…
¡¡¡UNCLE VANIA!!!
Y alguno dirá ¡Pues mira!
¡Mejor para ellos!
Seguro que ahora los rusos comerán más sano.
(Esperad, que es que hay gente que dice estas
cosas de forma no irónica…)
Por si alguno lo piensa: la respuesta es no:
el hecho de que McDonald’s se vaya de Rusia
no significa que los rusos se vayan a volver
más sanos.
Todo lo contrario.
Prácticamente todas las multinacionales se
han ido de Rusia.
Eso significa que los rusos ya no pueden comprar
muebles de Ikea, ni iPhones, ni camisetas
de Zara...
¡Y tampoco podrían pagarlos!
Para que os hagáis una idea, ha habido días
donde sólo había un único cajero automático
en todo San Petesburgo.
Mientras tanto, Putin no deja de censurar
páginas web, hay miles de personas en la
cárcel por participar en protestas contra
la guerra.
Y esto es sólo el principio.
No hace falta ser un premio nóbel de economía
para predecir que lo peor está por llegar.
Y eso explica lo siguiente.
El talento tecnológico se marcha de Rusia
mientras las sanciones occidentales empiezan
a morder
Y alguno dirá ¿Y dónde está el problema?
¡Mejor para los rusos que se queden!
¡Más sitio para aparcar!
Pues no.
Creedme: esto es toda una tragedia económica.
Pensadlo así: el recurso más importante
de un país no es ni su gas ni su petróleo:
es su gente.
Esto no es un mensaje políticamente correcto:
es la realidad.
El capital humano es fundamental para cualquier
economía.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, los que se van
de Rusia no son, precisamente, los más tontos.
En realidad, Rusia lleva sufriendo una fuga
de cerebros continua desde el año 2014.
Hablamos de abogados, contables y, sobre todo,
informáticos.
Es verdad que Rusia nunca ha sido el paraíso
de la tecnología.
Pero en un país de más de 144 millones de
habitantes hay cientos de miles de personas
con talento.
Por cierto: muchos de ellos son especialistas
en ciberseguridad.
Recordad todos los vídeos que hemos hecho
en VisualPolitik hablando de los hackers rusos.
Toda esa gente puede encontrar trabajo en
cualquier parte del mundo y muy bien pagado.
Sin embargo el punto de inflexión ha llegado
con la invasión de Ucrania.
Pensadlo bien: es ahora cuando las mayores
multinacionales se han marchado.
Por ejemplo, es en marzo de 2022 cuando las
Big 4 se han marchado del país.
Las big 4 son las 4 mayores auditoras del
mundo, ya sabéis, EY, Deloitte, PriceWaterHouseCoopers
y KPMG.
Estas 4 empresas daban empleo a más de 15.000
trabajadores cualificados.
Por supuesto, el hecho de que estas marcas
se vayan no significa que hayan despedido
a sus trabajadores.
Pensad que estas grandes consultoras trabajan
como una franquicia al más puro estilo de
McDonald´s.
Es decir, lo que antes era Deloitte Russia
ahora pasará a llamarse de otra forma.
Ahora bien, han perdido buena parte de sus
clientes.
Eso significa que la mayoría de los empleados
están ahora en baja temporal hasta que les
reubiquen en nuevos proyectos.
La pregunta es ¿De verdad van a ser capaces
de encontrar nuevos clientes de un día para
otro?
Lo más probable es que no.
Y eso significa miles de personas en el paro.
Personas que fácilmente pueden encontrar
un buen trabajo en otro país ¿Conclusión?
Antes de que les cierren las fronteras, se
marchan.
Y sí, habéis oído bien: antes de que cierren
las fronteras.
Porque el riesgo de que Rusia no les deje
salir es real.
De hecho, en todos los foros de internet recomiendan
borrar todos los mensajes de Whatsapp o Telegram
antes de dejar el país ¿Por qué?
Porque la policía rusa está haciendo auténticos
interrogatorios en el aeropuerto.
Cualquier mensaje de móvil que pueda interpretarse
como “anti Ruso” puede llevarles a la
cárcel o impedirles dejar el país.
Y os preguntaréis ¿A dónde están yendo
todos estos rusos?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¡SÁLVESE QUIÉN PUEDA!
Os voy a dar un ejemplo real aunque no puedo
dar nombres para respetar la privacidad.
Empresa rusa de informática con 500 trabajadores.
Tenía varios clientes en Japón.
En principio, no los han perdido.
Ahora bien: se tienen que marchar de Rusia
¿Qué han hecho?
Marcharse a Dubai con todo el equipo.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Dubai no ha sancionado a Rusia.
Así que el CEO de la empresa rusa ha montado
una nueva compañía en Dubai y ha movido
a toda su plantilla.
¡Pero esperad un momento, porque Dubai no
es el único lugar que está recibiendo rusos!
Por supuesto, si eres un millonario o un programador
de alto nivel, Dubai es un destino muy atractivo.
Pero tiene un problema: es muy caro ¿Qué
pasa con el resto de profesionales?
Pues, en la mayor parte de los casos, se están
llendo a destinos menos atractivos pero más
asequibles.
Países como Kazajistán, India o Georgia
están recibiendo miles de trabajadores rusos
en cuestión de semanas.
Y diréis ¿Pero quién querría irse a vivir
a Kazajistán?
Está claro, nadie ha dicho nunca “mi sueño
es vivir en Almaty” pero... pensadlo bien:
ahora mismo cualquier lugar es mejor que la
Rusia de Putin.
Por ejemplo, más de 25.000 personas se han
marchado ya a Georgia.
Entre ellos está uno de los YouTubers rusos
más conocidos en Occidente: NFKRZ, que incluso
ya ha subido su primer vídeo desde Tbilisi,
la capital de Georgia.
Sólo en el mes de febrero, 44.000 rusos cruzaron
la frontera con Finlandia.
El mes anterior, esta cifra era de menos de
27.000.
Y aquí es donde llegamos al gran problema
que denunciamos en este vídeo ¿Qué pasa
con esos rusos que llegan a Finlandia (es
decir, a la Unión Europea)?
¿Pueden buscar un trabajo?
¿Pueden comprar una casa?
¿Pueden integrarse en Europa?
Y la respuesta es...
¡NO!
Habéis oído bien: Europa está aceptando
rusos como turistas.
Es decir, con un visado que les permite quedarse
unos meses pero no buscar trabajo.
Y diréis ¡Bravo!
¡Qué decisión más inteligente!
¿Quién quiere que venga gente joven a trabajar
a Europa?
¿Quién necesita personas que vengan a pagar
las pensiones?
¿Entendéis lo que quiero decir?
Europa tiene dos problemas gigantescos: la
crisis de las pensiones y la escasez de mano
de obra.
Sí, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando: en
países como España parece un insulto decir
que hay escasez de mano de obra.
Pero lo cierto es que hay sectores donde es
casi imposible encontrar trabajadores.
Por ejemplo: todo lo que tenga que ver con
ciberseguridad.
Las empresas europeas están desesperadas
por encontrar especialistas en ciberseguridad.
Y los estados europeos están desesperados
por encontrar gente que pague pensiones.
Así que todos estos rusos que querrían venir
a Europa suponen dos oportunidades: una, descapitalizan
a Rusia porque les dejan sin sus mejores profesionales;
dos, nos ayudan a pagar pensiones y a ser
más competitivos.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué Europa los está
rechazando?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
ODIA A PUTIN, AMA A LOS RUSOS
Ya lo hemos contado en varios vídeos de VisualPolitik:
todos los países tienen programas de inmigración
especiales para atraer talento y dinero.
Independientemente de la visión que tengáis
cada uno sobre los inmigrantes, nadie pone
en duda que es bueno atraer talento y dinero.
Eso explica la famosa visa H1B1 de Estados
Unidos, por donde han entrado miles de personas
a Silicon Valley.
Y sí, en este apartado es donde también
podríamos meter todas esas “visas doradas”
con las que los oligarcas rusos entraron en
“Londongrado” o en otros lugares como
Marbella, en España.
De repente han llegado las sanciones: perfecto,
Europa no quiere más oligarcas rusos conectados
a Putin.
Nada que objetar a esto.
Pero...
¿Qué pasa con los profesionales?
¿Qué pasa con ese hacker ruso que tiene
30 años y que no tiene ninguna conexión
con Putin ni con su gobierno?
¿Por qué no se le puede contratar?
Diréis ¿Pero de verdad hay tantas empresas
deseosas de contratar a rusos?
La respuesta es que sí.
Os voy a poner otro ejemplo real donde no
puedo citar nombres por privacidad.
Multinacional del sector alimentación con
sedes por todo el mundo.
Vamos a llamar a esta empresa “ACME” por
ponerle un nombre.
Acaban de cerrar sus oficinas en Moscú debido
a las sanciones.
Sin embargo, desde su sede en Barcelona, “ACME
ESPAÑA” quiere contratar a buena parte
de la plantilla de “ACME RUSIA”.
Son perfiles muy útiles que no quieren perder...
¡Y aquí llega el problema!
Los empleados de ACME RUSIA llegan al consulado
de España en Rusia y les dicen...
¡Lo sentimos, no podemos procesar vuestro
visado!
¡No podemos demostrar vuestra experiencia
profesional!
¿Por qué?
Porque ACME RUSIA ya no existe ¡Desapareció
antes de ayer!
Dicho de otra forma: en el curriculum de toda
esa gente figura que han trabajado en una
empresa fantasma.
Y esto hace legalmente imposible procesar
su visado ¿Por qué?
Pues atentos.
La principal forma para entrar legalmente
en España desde fuera de la Unión Europea
es con la llamada LEY DE INVERSIONES, aprobada
en 2014.
Casi todos los países Europeos tienen leyes
parecidas.
A esto es a lo que nos referimos normalmente
como las “visas doradas”.
Esta ley permite conseguir un visado de dos
formas distintas: invirtiendo una gran suma
de dinero en España o bien siendo lo que
se llama un “alto profesional”.
Y diréis ¿Cómo define la ley lo que es
un “alto profesional”?
Pues muy sencillo: se trata de un profesional
con un perfil tan especializado que es casi
imposible sustituirlo por una persona local.
Para eso, es necesario presentar títulos
universitarios y experiencia profesional ¿El
problema?
Las universidades rusas no están homologadas
con las europeas.
Y la experiencia profesional de un ruso es
indemostrable en este momento.
Es tan sencillo como eso: los consulados europeos
no están aceptando los curriculums de miles
de profesionales rusos.
Y esto tiene tres derivadas muy preocupantes.
La primera es que manda el mensaje equivocado
a los rusos: ¡Putin tiene razón!
¡Occidente odia a todos y cada uno de los
rusos!
¡La rusofobia existe!
La segunda es que Europa está perdiendo una
oportunidad muy buena para atraer talento
y contribuyentes.
La tercera es que Europa no está generando
el efecto llamada que necesita.
Porque no es lo mismo dejar Rusia sabiendo
que tus únicas alternativas son Kazajistán
o la India, que dejar Rusia sabiendo que te
espera una vida mucho mejor en la Unión Europea.
Dicho de otra forma: si ves este vídeo desde
un consulado en Rusia...
¡Ponte las pilas!
¡El tiempo apremia!
Y bien digo: el tiempo apremia.
La ventana de oportunidad es única.
Es cuestión de tiempo que Rusia cierre sus
fronteras.
Es decir, que al Kremlin no le quede más
remedio que prohibir a todos sus ciudadanos
abandonar el país.
No sería la primera vez que ocurre.
Desde el año 1922, la antigua Unión Soviética
cerró sus puertas a todos sus ciudadanos.
En 1961, la República Democrática de Alemania
llegó a construir un muro en Berlín para
evitar que nadie cruzara la frontera a Berlín
Occidental.
Todo esto se debe a una razón: Rusia no puede
permitirse perder a más talento.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Se os ocurre alguna razón por la que Europa
NO debería aceptar trabajadores rusos?
¿De verdad Europa llegará a abrir sus puertas
al talento ruso que se marcha?
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener esto en la
guerra de Ucrania?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.